okay there's been huge blowback from
some to my interview with all right
leader white nationalist Richard Spencer
and every time I do an interview with a
controversial figure with deplorable
views there will be critiques that I am
giving someone a platform that doesn't
deserve a platform that if I'm having
someone on at all I am effectively
promoting their views there's a fair
criticism or debate to be had about
whether general broader interests are
better served by exploring where these
horrible views come from versus
pretending they don't exist and sort of
no platforming then my view and you know
this if you've been watching the show
for a while is that I am of the belief
that we should actually find out where
extremism comes from and figure out what
are the sources what are the basis for
these beliefs now when I do these
interviews if you're familiar with the
show you know that I don't yell and
scream and tell the person that they're
a horrible person I don't know what that
would achieve what I seek to do in being
cordial is try to figure out what is the
basis for the beliefs of these
individuals and I think Pat people who
are familiar with the show tend to know
that that's the strategy whether it's
the God hates [ __ ] people Glenn Miller
or the Koran burner whoever I also just
disagree with the fact that you're
giving them a platform if you enabled
him to speak for maybe half an hour
unchallenged I could see that being
giving him a platform but you're
challenging him the whole way yeah and
again challenging some people could
fairly say David you didn't challenge
him loudly enough because you weren't
screaming at every single thing he said
you know if I do that we won't even
really have an interview it will not
really be a conversation where we could
learn anything unfortunately a few
progressive liberal media people really
didn't like the fact that I did this
interview one of them was liberal radio
host Nicole Sandler who I know
personally haven't seen her for a while
but no personally she tweeted she said a
number of things but it started with Dee
Pakman you seriously interviewed Richard
Spencer why would you give him the time
of day and it sort of escalated from
there she ended up on following me on
Twitter and say
that I was just doing absolutely the
wrong thing and that it crossed a line
it triggered a really big back-and-forth
with a bunch of people on Twitter sort
of debating as she went on to say I
don't understand giving people like that
more room to spread vile hatred they
don't deserve a mic go get those ratings
by the way I've interviewed many people
with whom I disagreed don't mistake my
stance I just won't promote hate mongers
or NOx nazis its clickbait shame on you
I hope you're all trite listeners loved
it I was saddened that this this was
what Nicole felt about the interview
then Abby Martin formerly of RT
currently of the Empire files against
someone I know personally she sent out a
tweet last night there were a number of
tweets but it started with at D Pakman
my Twitter handle it's so great you're
giving Nazis a platform and treating
their ideology as just differing
political views totally what we need
right now triggered another significant
back-and-forth that lasted many many
hours again my view is you can't really
debate such insane ideas the point is
let's figure out where it comes from and
expose that this is a non insignificant
part in the case of all trite beliefs
this is a not insignificant part of
Donald Trump being President of the
United States where do we draw the line
if the policy is you don't interview
people whose views are really vile what
about a gay a guest that's anti-gay I
find that deplorable what about someone
who says gay people are going to hell or
people who don't care about poverty
that's hugely deplorable
it seems very arbitrary to me to come up
with some sort of list of whose views
are too vile to ever be given the
opportunity to appear on a program do
you only interview people you agree with
what about far left people who I might
share ideological perspectives in terms
of policy issues but who believe that
violence is justifiable for political
gain versus me who would prefer not to
see violence for political gain well
that I think that we're opening up a
sort of dangerous door with that policy
vice land did some ride-alongs I don't
know if it's neo-nazis or KKK or
whatever they went to cross burnings or
some insanity
does that cause or normalize cross
burnings and neo-nazism I don't think so
during those pieces you don't have a
host yelling and saying you're a
terrible person the entire time I think
the exposition really speaks for itself
I also talked about some viewers again I
think mostly the viewers who are longer
time viewers of the show and get the
interviews get that this is not a new
thing this isn't new to the show we did
the Glenn Miller interview years ago we
we interviewed Terry Jones the Koran
burner people from Westboro Baptist
Church we've interviewed many extremists
and I have learned a lot about how does
someone like this exist in the world and
sort of generate their their worldview
last thing I want to touch on the idea
of normalizing the normalizing thing
relies entirely on the idea that the
audience is going to be tricked into all
of a sudden thinking white nationalism
is a really good thing based on some guy
having a conversation about it on my
show making pretty horrible arguments I
would I would add I don't think that the
audience pat is going to all of a sudden
say wow the white nationalist was
allowed to speak I'm super convinced by
him I think maybe I should look at white
nationalism as no of course our audience
isn't going to blindly go along I mean I
think there could be a line there but I
think the line gets drawn where
someone's advocating for violence or
making threats against people it's not
just voicing their opinion that I even
think that that's a difficult line
because someone could see the interview
with Spencer and say listen David he
wasn't advocating for physical violence
but the suggestion that races should
live separately and there should be a
peaceful ethnic separation that it's
ideologically and politically violent I
wouldn't disagree with that I wouldn't
disagree with that which is why I think
even that line Pat it's an interesting
idea I think even that's hard to draw I
guess so but I mean Richard Spencer
wouldn't even elaborate on how that
would be done how the races would be
separated yeah keep sending me your
thoughts on this I think it's a debate
that I would be lying if I said I wasn't
up later than I planned to be last night
as a result of this I mean really I
think that this is not a good direction
for critiques of journalism to go I
guess fundamentally that's sort of my
gut
feeling about it